in this film I play a real man father
Gabriella Moore I am the chief Exorcist
of the Vatican my position was a point
it was actually a real job in the
Vatican the majority of cases do not
require an exorcism 98 I recommended by
him to doctors and psychiatrists the
other two percent I call it evil and he
was a very controversial character he
performed thousands of exorcisms and had
not only done it for 36 years but had
documented the things that he'd
experienced if evil does not exist what
then is the role of the church he's
discovered some of the darkest days of
the Catholic church
I buried the truth here it's a very dark
Pursuit and it is Faith gave him a
certain level of courage to do the job
whatever you do you only do because God
allows him
closer